tonight we hear from a parent as the man
seemingly has been released from the
Clark County Detention Center Ryan
mathie with this story
so there's always a parent
Elizabeth McIver used to live in a
garden-style apartment complex off
Westcliff and buffalo that was until
late August and I noticed that there is
a small handful of children jetting
across the apartment complex to go into
this older man's apartment
this man 58 year old Kevin Fraser was
arrested for allegedly enticing children
with candy to enter his apartment
repeatedly back in August caught most
recently by the MacGyver family they say
he was wearing only boxers that exposed
his private parts it's like straight out
of a movie and their kids aren't the
only ones as some children played down
here up there the man would stand on his
balcony nearly half dressed offering
candy to those who came up how old were
these kids
probably five to eleven Robert Thompson
lives directly under the unit in
question now vacant but unbeknownst to
him his neighbor would make children do
push-ups pull-ups and jumping jacks in
front of him to receive the candy his
arrest report shows I knew he was single
and he knew he lived alone
it didn't feel right but according to
the arrest report the children were
untouched not enough of a justification
for parents who knows how long this was
going on who knows how many children
were truly truly truly involved and it's
such a scary situation that I mean just
knowing that he's out even if it is on
house arrest with monitoring all that
stuff it doesn't it doesn't feel great
while jail records show the man is still
in custody court records show his five
thousand dollar bail was posted the day
after he was arrested and he was out on
house arrest in late September Ryan
reached out to Metro to confirm his
custody at this point we're awaiting
their response Frazier expected back in
court next Thursday where it appears he
is in negotiations on a plea